many people believe that central bankers
are asleep at the wheel and they're not
paying attention to bitcoin or the
lightning network but we now have
verifiable proof that that is not the
case the federal reserve bank of
cleveland recently released a white
paper analyzing the lightning network
and talking about how it will help
bitcoin transition into a better means
of payment that's not exactly what
you're hearing in the mainstream media
the paper was published in june of 2022
and as gabor points out here the federal
reserve bank of cleveland wrote that
paper of how it's turning bitcoin into
money bitcoin innovation is tangible
real and increasingly recognized haters
are in disbelief
as we look at this paper we can see the
lightning network turning bitcoin into
money it's a means of netting bitcoin
payments outside of blockchain and they
find a significant association between
lightning adoption and reduced
blockchain congestion now if we jump
into the piece itself there's three
specific parts that i think are worth
calling out the first is that they
outline four specific conclusions they
believe that the development of the
lightning network may have consequences
for welfare first bitcoin has become a
more efficient payment system making
users better off
second fewer transactions needed to be
recorded on layer one means that less
memory and energy are needed to run a
bitcoin node
third by reducing fees the lightning
network reduces the incentive for
bitcoin miners to use large amounts of
computing power meaning less energy use
and positive consequences for the
environment and fourth less blockchain
congestion may mean lower barriers to
arbitrage across cryptocurrency exchange
thereby improving market liquidity as
well now the federal reserve bank of
cleveland also finds that adoption of
the lightning network has led to a
reduction in bitcoin blockchain
congestion and lower mining fees the
results they're significant and they
cannot be explained by any other changes
including in demand for blockchain space
nor by other technological developments
they believe that lightning network can
help bitcoin achieve greater scalability
allowing it to operate better as a
payment system according to their
results if the lightning network had
existed in 2017 congestion could have
been 93
lower the lightning network works in
their opinion now the federal reserve
bank of cleveland concludes that the
usage of the lightning network is
associated with reduced mempool
congestion in bitcoin and with those
lower fees they suggest that the
off-chain netting benefits of the
lightning network can help bitcoin to
scale and function better as a means of
payment they also believe that lightning
network loosens a key technological
constraint by allowing payments to be
settled more quickly
now you can take a couple of things away
from this white paper first the central
bankers are not asleep at the wheel
they're paying attention they're
studying this technology they're trying
to understand what works and what
doesn't work and to see them publish
something on the lightning network is
quite bullish in my opinion the second
thing is that even the central bankers
agree the lightning network that layer 2
scalability solution is making bitcoin a
better means of payment and if we can
reduce that technological barrier and
make bitcoin faster and cheaper to
transact it means that bitcoin has more
utility and is likely to be adopted by
more people so as a reminder no one
knows what the future holds but if the
central bankers are publishing white
papers today and they're actually being
bullish and positive on bitcoin and the
lightning network it gives me hope that
eventually we are going to see central
banks both in the united states and
globally start to adopt bitcoin and the
bitcoin payment rails it's simply
superior technology and at the end of
every single technology innovation what
we get is a winner based on what the
consumer wants and right now even the
central banks understand if this is
cheaper and faster eventually consumers
will adopt it